[Music]
hey holy welcome back to the break group
so good to see you roomies you breakers
out there uh this is our daily show that
keeps you updated on just what's going
on and nerd news it's monday aren't you
thrilled about that don't you hate the
weekend couldn't wait for monday to come
around
we're so glad to have you here joining
us on the break room uh coming up we've
got some major updates in the
ghostbusters universe i'm busting to
talk about it uh first look at black
panther wakanda forever and we'll travel
across
the spider bird
isn't that adorable isn't that adorable
hey folks you said she should never come
back but she's here again
oh my gosh i didn't think i would be
allowed yet here i am you all got plenty
of sleep over the weekend still got a
job today i'm very grateful we're here
last friday go back and watch it go back
and watch it but also joining us today
we got jessica clements hello jessica
perfectly sober perfectly sober in every
way if she were mary poppins and she had
that little measuring tape it would say
practically sober in every
way uh and next to me right here you
know him you'll love him he fights buses
across la county it's tommy bechdel not
guilty y'all got to feel me tom the
maxum off back in the house bring my
camera up close for a second listen to
me
you little conniving
thieves donating 700 plus dollars on a
day that i'm going making a fool out of
me
make a phone out of me i make a fool out
of you you want to ask questions to the
super chat today you better pay up baby
you better pay
up because tom dean answered questions
for five dollars tom just going 20 and
above okay
uh uh if you were here last friday uh
you saw john on the panel john's not
here because you killed him with your
your super john john dr manhattan he
just blew into matter and now he's
reassembling in our office loaded into a
g flat after the g fuel dude i i was
scared for him for the rest of the night
i was concerned we lost him he's alive
and well we probably pooped out an
entire g-fuel rocket
oh my goodness well uh if you do want to
throw those super chats out we do love
them and we love your questions and
everything you've got to say but we have
our swear jar chat redemption going
today we're not allowed to curse on this
show it's a clean show this is a show
for mothers grandmothers fathers
children everyone across there we're not
gonna curse but
but
if we raise a hundred dollars in super
chats we unlock the swear jar and i
think we'll let you guys vote today on
who gets a swear when when the swears
become aware yeah and i don't mean to go
rogue here but i am going to go a bit
rogue because i asked john if we could
do some special things with the swears
just to kind of you know give some
incentive and he said absolutely not and
i said guess what i don't care so
if we raise three hundred dollars we're
going to do a special swear for whoever
puts us over that 300 dollars i swear
for you swear of your choice request to
swear okay and if we raise 400 which i
have zero faith in any of you
cheapskates
uh
we will take the swear jar and i'll take
my hammer and i will break the swear jar
with mjolnir okay and it will be
unlimited swears for the rest of the
episode whoa okay that seems dangerous
and if you pay 700
all in one go
you can put us on speaker phone and we
will swear at your landlord for reason
yes requests what like request to swear
candy
but you know what helps you pay rent
headlines
uh as i tease at the top we're busting
over here busting with ghosts
because uh last wednesday last
wednesday's ghostbuster day run a trio
of announcements furthering the
franchise's story uh first up a new
ghostbusters cartoon coming to netflix
from ghostbuster afterlife co-writers
gil keenan and jason reitman you know
i'm an old man uh they had a certain
ghostbusters
the real ghostbusters yeah i loved that
guy also this just seems like a good
deal because don't they still have the
one kid from stranger things that's in
ghostbusters after yeah also they're
just like we can just put the budget
together yeah netflix is like that we'll
keep them anywhere we can uh so that'll
be fun but also there's gonna be a new
ghostbusters animated movie uh which is
in the works the ghostbusters animated
movie is a new feature and will be
directed by jennifer kluska kluska
who recently directed hotel transylvania
iv and chris pot prionoski now it's
going to be like it's going to be silly
it's gotta be silly chris
pryonoski i saw i directed some episodes
like metal opalic metalocalypse
apocalypse oh josh
yeah i don't know i'm not speaking
correctly if you remember er dr green
started speaking poorly and they found a
brain tumor is that what happened to me
who knows uh stay tuned all week to see
if i survive uh
this new animated movie that will
explore new characters and new story
lines in the ghostbusters universe
and then finally the ghostbusters
afterlife sequel is also receiving an
update uh
which came out during ghostbusters day
the creators aren't releasing too much
information what else is new other than
the working code name for the movie
which is
firehouse firehouse
this one makes more sense but i love
code names for tv shows for bob's
burgers the movie the code name was dj
jazzy hands
no one knew what the title of the bob's
burgers movie was gonna be
and it was just called the boss bob's
burger movie
two days coming up with that name a
whole retreat uh the quote from uh i
believe reitman said was like the last
time we saw the ecto one was driving
back into manhattan the home of the
ghostbusters yes and i also think in
that press conference he referred to it
as the spangler family saga oh okay i
have a feeling that the spanglers that
we met uh will be returned we'll be
returning to manhattan maybe uh did you
guys see the ghostbusters afterlife of
course yeah that was so good i enjoyed
it spoiler alert echo one drives into
manhattan
thank you sorry we ruined the ending
that's it there's no ghosts they don't
find any ghosts they just wanna be no
ghost in the movie this is so weird
demogorgons though
yeah that kid can't catch your brain
there's no ghosts there's so much
busting it's uncomfortable really
they're not busting ghosts
you don't want to bust all the ghosts
because if you bust all the ghosts
there's no ghosts left right
ghost is also a code name for it oh keep
going
oh my god uh ryan johnson tweeted out
that benoit blank's next case uh is
gonna be called the which is the
follow-up to knives out is called glass
onion
glass onion like the beetles tune yeah i
was told this was a beetle song sing a
little glass on you for me i don't know
how glass onion goes yeah everyone keeps
saying glasses i know the beetle song i
just wear that it's a beatles song i
want to know what it has to do with the
movie well i imagine if we remember the
first movie was all about donuts having
holes
and what that means right the whole the
center of the donut and all that this is
about layers if we know our shrimp
so what you're saying is that knives out
too is a direct is is like a sequel to
like shrek's yeah i think it's a
backdoor pilot for shrek yeah it's
another direct food metaphor is what it
is drinking killer shrek i didn't kill
her
grounder in my swamp oh jesus that's a
great that's a great thing that was a
really good one i really like that
thanks guys another headline great to be
back miss marvel executive producer
bishop k ali noted that she did have
some other ideas on people who on how
people would know about the final battle
in avengers in game
but those ideas were shot down by marvel
studios president kevin feige uh if we
know from the first episode of ms marvel
she mentions the podcast that uh scott
wang spilled all the the juice yes uh
but uh what she said that kevin was
quote i was like kevin what if there was
like drones and a live stream at the
battle of endgame and he was like bishop
no yes yeah i like that he shut that
down real quick yeah if i'm ever dying
on a strange planet please don't
livestream
where it was right it's that it's the
avengers compound in like upstate new
york it's kind of rural but i'm sure
some farms in the distance were like i
need more over there i'm more irritated
that he immediately shot it down without
thinking about like this show is a lot
about the internet a lot about digital
entertainment and this is how this girl
does it and this is how the gen x do it
i just wonder
i guess the live stream part makes sense
because i don't know how many of those
drones would have made it out of there
yeah
well we know like the d or dc would be
like confiscating
data everywhere wouldn't let any of that
that sneak away i mean we've always
theorized here at the channel that like
any one of uh tony stark's built suits
like environment suit rescue the
spider-man suit war machine they'll have
like built-in cameras and would monitor
everything so i eventually some of that
footage might be leaked you could do a
freedom of information request get that
leaked out to the public i don't know
but bishop no be sure absolutely not and
then and then the pond the darth vader
pod that kevin feige sleeps in closed
yeah just like leave my temple goodbye
another thing just made us look like
dracula
he is dracula with that hat the hat
protects him from the sun for a reason
oh it's true we'll find out is feige the
living dead we'll never know
us now
that's why he wanted to that's why he
wanted all that press all that internet
drama he was like it's about me smiling
it's my time this is my story finally
being told to the
uh we read a poll in the chat there what
ghostbusters announcement are you most
excited about 48
very excited for that afterlife sequel i
don't disagree but i think let's get
that animated movie a little hype yeah
i'm more excited for the anime excited
get excited
i'm sorry to go back is the animated
series based off the afterlife
i guess so i don't know what they
weren't super clear uh they weren't but
it is it's reitman and uh gilkina i
imagine it exists in the same universe
it would be new characters maybe it
could be like the ghostbusters yeah
washington well they were specifically
the movie is going to be different new
characters that maybe i mean might cross
over with the existing characters but i
wonder if it'll be maybe remember they
had that um
ghostbusters like evolution or whatever
it was without the game the video no
they had the new cartoon that was like
uh
like egon was the only remaining
ghostbuster and then they were like
kids that were fighting kids children
let your children fight babies fighting
ghosts ghosts why not it's perfectly
safe
uh we also got our first look at black
panther wakanda forever specifically
character posters for the for sure and
okay via some sprite promo posters uh
we'll throw those up on the screen there
not super clear photos uh we looked at i
was looking at kogi's uniform it looks
exactly the same not much change there
sherry looks like she might be doing
some work on the enterprise yeah she's
got a like a little tracksuit thing
going on here we also don't know if
she's gonna be based out of wakanda or
if she'll be working in oakland yeah at
that science center they wanted to set
up there yeah i don't know but yeah she
could be running a marathon i was
thinking
i was thinking about that with her
hairstyle for the promo specifically i
was like because in wakanda uh yeah
you're either okay and you don't have
hair or your hair is actually like so
incredibly detailed but this i'm like oh
this does look like something i would
get done in the bay area like so i was
like maybe she is still there
it is interesting how like you know in
through in the mcu costumes change all
the time they evolve they gotta sell
their toys they gotta make things look
different but colier's uniform has
pretty much stayed the same
has not changed at all also it can't
change well it can change but the whole
team's what happens you gotta do
everything everybody but she's the boss
right because she has this she gets the
difference she gets a different sphere
different better oh the boss spear
and finally one of the things we're
really excited about spiderman no way
home is heading back to theaters in a no
way home extended cut the more fun stuff
version and more fun stuff 15 extra
minutes oh baby
uh there's gonna be some of the scenes
uh leaked out what they're gonna be
there's gonna be an extended
interrogation scene
um we're going to see more of peter's
day at midtown high uh yeah which one
what are we talking about the
interrogation with the agent are you
talking about agent cleary okay i didn't
know what about daredevils
well we do know there's going to be the
undercroft montage we're going to see
some more of that uh happy's very good
lawyer which could be memorable could be
someone else i don't know
no because he said i'm a really good
lawyer right when he got it right so i
see him do you know he's going to handle
happy for sure what if someone else is
going to handle happy real time who's
going to keep happy happy by handling it
that'd be crazy if it is just she-hulk
what if it's
uh i was trying to think of a famous
celebrity celebrity lawyer but they were
all dead johnny cochran he's dead uh
tmz he was a lawyer first uh harvey
levin oh okay
i'm dead
confirmed though he's still alive you're
here on the bridge we know tarvy eleven
from this show we do not target i hope i
never see harvey living again uh one of
the scenes that seems to have the most
additional run time the spidey's hanging
out yeah i want to be adorable
you want to be so cute
i want to see them snug and hang out
tickets for this are going to go on sale
august 9th and it'll be in theaters on
september 2nd all right are you guys on
the track can i go see spider-man again
are you thirsty to see spider-man yeah
when did you go see spider-man it's
pretty long for that extra 15 minutes
yes 15 scares me scares my bladder
i guess i really you know when you can
go pee i've seen it in theaters twice
yeah i mean i held out when the digital
release came out i held out for that 4k
uh ultra high definition disc i don't
trust that
[Applause]
so i was like super excited to see it
and like high definition but it is fun
seeing them in movie theaters on the big
screen i don't know it's a lot of fun
people get i like it get hype america
uh it looks like the chat's pretty
pretty closely split about whether they
go see it uh in theaters again 54 saying
yes 45 percent saying oh wow pretty
pretty even
even there guys you didn't roll out for
morbius again but you're gonna roll out
for spiderman what if it does worse than
morbius i don't think i don't think
that's actually possible don't think
that would be amazing what if i send you
guys morbius right now and overlaid over
morbia's face as kevin feige with that
hat would you guys watch it then oh i
would definitely watch kevin feige's
star what what could we get like a
marvelous jib jab
like kevin feige in the morbius costume
like doing that and the music behind it
i don't know our jib jabs like that
that was like what it was when i was in
high school
you guys
enough with this jib jab or more with
the jib jack we've got a bunch of
updates for spider-man across the spider
verse not across the universe across the
spider verse um and
clearly i need help um do you mind
moving this light
i'll do it just as long as it doesn't
make my face look worse
there you go perfect i already am not
wearing glasses because i did this to
myself oh no so how does one top kingpin
and dr olivia octavius you may ask was
spider-man villain spot so we're now
seeing
what are you making those noises for i'm
just pretending how does someone ha ha
that's someone
i was just trying to hype you up
okay well who was the voice of kingpin
in the across season it was uh oh who
was uh
uh what's his it wasn't he voices the
nfl commercials uh oh uh leave schreiber
yeah leave striper was yeah yeah i'm
pretty sure it was like that's true
that's correct john says but every once
in a while when he was like
like the buffalo bills makes their
toughest opponent in week four he was
like i'm gonna get you spiderman oh my
gosh the only thing that could beat the
seattle seahawks was their complete lack
of stop
stop okay
disregard the horrible noise coming from
tommy right now about the sales
but
we have spot our new villain for uh for
across the spider verse played by jason
schwartzman who though is arguably an
older obscure spider-man villain his
entire body is covered in
interdimensional portals that can send
him anywhere um i think we might have a
graphic not from the comic that i sent
you john but maybe a graphic from what
sony posted there it is yeah so he can
sling his enemies hits right back at
them like wong did abomination
as you can see with um
spider gwen uh the cake is coming
through the other portal
um so i showed some footage right at
this event of like spider-man across the
stage yeah they do yes they haven't
released it online yeah i'm going to go
through a play-by-play of some of this
i'm sorry the discussion is a little bit
big and then i get into you guys
i will keep it so i will wait for myself
okay spots uh origin is spots aka dr
jonathan on um his first appearance was
in spectacular spider-man 19 that came
out 1975 issue number 98 he worked with
kingpin trying to create a more super
henchman and in doing so they made a
machine that duplicated cloak superpower
which is trans-dimensional portals and
he stepped in it
as one does as one does he steps in and
when it's having a little uh iffy moment
i'll just go in and fix this
[Applause]
speaking of which i think i see john
materializing
somewhere out in the hallway oh it's
just shaft right now
coursing down an esophagus and then a
shaft so he jumped into it tried to fix
it was like i'm gonna fix this blah blah
immediately gets shot into a spotty like
dimension and when he comes back from
that spotty dimension he is this in fact
a spot looks like cruella de vil's like
i mean spot is like the name of the main
puppy
and they combined the dna of spot from
101 dalmatians
it's all making sense now oh gosh though
it technically hasn't been confirmed
that we're gonna go with that origin
story four spot but that is the origin
from him in the 1975 comics what we will
see in spider-man across this uni
spider-verse i always want to say
universe is we'll see more gwen stacy
from earth65 we'll be seeing vulture
played by uh
jorma you're taco i'm a horrible person
oh wait the one that's quiet well
well there's two that are more quiet
than any sandburg there's two that are
in a hot rod yeah and then there's one
he's the little brother in hot rod
protectors
i will protect you okay robin got it the
quiet one spider spider woman will be
played by izza ray rachel dratch will
also be playing a school counselor and
of course we can forget oscar isaac
coming back as miguel o'hara when i say
coming back because we saw him in the
close the quick post-credits scene um
playing miguel o'hara and miguel is not
a spider-man
or at least the one in this one is not
he is not a spider-man he and when i say
that he wasn't bit by radioactive spider
he just has advanced technology and made
a lot of equipment that has like nails
in the he got his nails so he can climb
and he has now a device that can help
him go through different portals um so
he is like batman but honestly a little
bit smarter smarter in my opinion wow i
love him more his sidekick is just a a a
like uh uh what do you call it when you
can't see it but it's there and you can
kind of like translucent yeah it's like
uh opaque
what a snoop
did you say snoop dogg holograms they
did snoop dogg with tupac foreign sees a
lot of holograms
either way and we're also going to be
getting a new spidey suit uh which
we haven't really seen they just talked
about okay so from the play-by-play that
sony did give on twitter he's struggling
being a part-time superhero and he's
struggling being a part-time student so
is gwen stacy we get a sequence from the
film where gwen meets up with her dad
who is a do it by the books cop kind of
guy responding to a disturbance at the
guggenheim museum we get a pregnant
jessica drew aka spider-woman and unlike
oh we already talked about this
we already talked about this so
ultimately my best guess is that we see
miguel as the threat in the story but at
first but realize that the bigger threat
is spot because spot would use his
powers to just go through dimensions and
steal from pc so we think uh miguel's
like because he's spider-man
2099 or something like 20
10.99
1099 independent contractor uh it is 99
depending on something correct me in
chat uh please please tell me how wrong
i am guys call in if you know the answer
our phones are live now so please you
know call the number you know
2099 i was originally right now i don't
know why i ever doubted myself i should
never doubt myself i'm constantly right
a thousand percent of the time that's
why i tell my wife every day uh
so he's jumping through universes
angrily like
why do we think he'll be the villain
because well because he was if you
remember from the post-credits scene he
had a track on what was happening with
wilson fisk where everyone was switching
dimensions and all this stuff was
happening so i think he's just trying to
go out of his way to fix it or make sure
that thank you everyone in the chat
saying 2099. thank you thank you that's
enough nerds
so i think enough i think he's trying to
correct the situation that happened and
it's not making it better that there's
now a villain named spot that can just
jump through whatever they got
so they think he might be the villain
because he's coming in yeah and he's
probably fighting them immediately could
they retcon the spot's origin story and
maybe spot is an assistant to miguel
o'hara and then oak miguel is making his
teleporter they could devices for his
own suit and then spot accidentally
steps in it they could do that because
in the post-credits scene that we see
layla his hologram that builds and helps
things with him there she was like she
had a line that was like you're going to
be the first person to do this or the
first person not to make it because they
didn't know it was like a dummy oh yes
watch they were just like it's our first
try let's hope it works so they could
have been duplicating it from his powers
they told me that in a pizza hut all you
can eat buffet once when i said i was
gonna kill it i was gonna finish it off
they said you'll either be the first
person to do this or you'll be the first
person to die oh my god the first person
to die huh yeah do you think spy is like
going around stealing vanessa's and like
putting them that'd be i was thinking
about how great a lot of people have
died at pizza hut tommy just really
quick sorry do you think there's been a
lot of deaths guys put in the chat how
many people have died i think i think
pizza hut works like disney world yeah
well that garlic butter is basically
embalming fluid isn't it pretty much but
i love garlic so spot as the main
villain like i think you were right and
kind of saying he's not like a super
well-known villain he isn't no one his
you saw the bring up that image again
please how gross he looks uh no no sorry
the image i got from the comic books
from this uh there it is he's so silly
look at that he looks like freddy
krueger really nice thighs though
if you put him in a pair of heels you
look amazing i'm sure there's a an uh
gucci has made an outfit that's that of
that in heels
but i think he's just so goofy that they
didn't think about how and i'm so happy
they picked it for across the spider
verse i don't think they thought about
how important that is like the uh the
multiverse is yeah it's getting
convoluted with everyone's hacking it
but it's like okay let's get someone
that's actual powers to do that and not
only did we grab america chavez now we
also have spot we have a villain a
villain version so it's like yeah he
kind of sucks in the 70s but now but now
he's definitely a redemption a
redemption jason schwartzman doing the
voice absolutely i'm going to be so into
this guy he's going to be so cool he's
going to be very excited for this one i
love the first one and i'm i'm super
hyped i'm glad
i'm glad you're all so excited because i
get to talk about something i'm excited
about oh yeah
i want to thank my dear friends at helix
mattress for sponsoring us today oh yeah
i myself is camera three working or am i
staring into the void
camera three is on right
i myself am the proud owner of a helix
mattress it allows me to sleep so
soundly so i can create all these
dynamic mandatory fun segments that you
all know and love and demand we do love
them right in and
send me
crying cameo messages and
oh they signed up for a camera i can't
sleep because there was no mandatory fun
well guess what sleep soundly on your
helix mattress
now i live with roommates some call them
children i call them roommates and
they're loud and inconsiderate my helix
mattress is my best shot and a
comfortable night's sleep joey i'm
pleading with you if you're watching
please take out the trash it's your week
buddy please joey once a week okay once
a month it's your week to take out the
trash you can't just keep putting it in
paper bags but those aren't extra trash
cans okay anyway helix sleep has a quiz
that takes just two minutes to complete
and matches your body type and sleep
preference to the perfect mattress for
you why would you buy a mattress made
for someone else i slept on a stranger's
mattress once
every time you go to a hotel it wasn't
any fun
i bring my own sheets to hotels stop
sleeping on strange mattresses with
helix you're getting a mattress that you
know will be perfect for you and the way
you sleep everybody's unique let's face
it we're all beautiful snowflakes each
one deserving of our own special place
in the fields of paradise and helix
knows that so they have several
different mattress models to choose from
they have soft medium and firm
mattresses you know me i like to sink as
peep down into a soft mattress as
possible like i'm being devoured alive
by the sarlacc
they have mattresses that are great for
cooling you down if you sleep hot like
me sleep like a volcano mattress is
great for spinal alignment to prevent
morning aches and pains and even a helix
plus mattress for plus size sleepers and
gosh helix if you're listening send me
one of those mattresses i need a
mattress for a big boy
there's too much junk in my trunk for my
standard helix mattress now it holds up
because it's a fine product but i need a
helix plus now just go to helixsleep.com
room take their two minute sleep quiz
and they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life if you're like so if
you're like me someone who agonizes
about tests and quizzes you can't fail
this quiz okay there are no f's
everybody gets an a and everybody gets a
mattress that will be very comfortable
helix is offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners that's one for
hugging and one for under your head okay
so our listing is just go to
helixsleep.com
break room for 200 off and two free
pillows that's helix sleep.com slash
break room i like i like uh i had a pump
a pillow for the head and a pillow for
the arm i made a i made a body pillow
that's the exact size and shape of me
i put the pillow through the legs
personally
absolutely nice nice interesting just
need something all right we also want to
remind you to go to new rockstars
newrockstarsmerch.com and check out our
latest latest obsession shirt cosmic
daydream inspired by the miss marvel
show on disney plus beautiful shirt
beautiful show and when you buy this
limited edition latest obsession shirt
you unlock the ability to have a custom
shout out which will appear on our
inside marvel after show which is the
miss marvel after show that's right
hosted by eric voss and mt mr tayman
himself uh and they might even read it
out right on the uh read it out loud on
the air live on the air live to tape
whatever it is uh but check out our
limited edition latest obsession merch
uh because once it's gone it's gone for
good you'll never see it again that's it
uh newrockstarsmarch.com because you'll
check it out um you know what else is
live and only coming once what
paddington three paddington paddington
three
did you know that we're going all the
way down to darkest peru we're getting
that marmalade baby get your marmalade
heckin ready
all dogs must be carried when we go to
darkest peru
i'm jonathan brown and i love steam
trains okay
what are you talking about something
else what are you talking about
something i just wanted to say it's like
you activated her sleeper oh my god
what was that
boxcar
[Music]
she goes crazy until she gets marmalade
there's nevada paddington three it has
been confirmed it's coming out and
winning three kids so excited have they
not gone to peru yet
i haven't seen a single pack
that's where he's from it's time for
mandatory fun what's real mandatory fun
starts now oh my god patty take three is
out
it's time for mandatory fun the segment
that i skipped for three straight days
because i wanted to starve you people
i wanted to make you hungry i wanted to
make you earn it play the graphic again
again
[Laughter]
never mind we can talk about 23 again
if we're doing if we're doing plot uh
predictions which we might
in mandatory fun coming up next after
this graphic
[Music]
wait afterwards
wrong graphics
different graphic
he wants the real one give him the real
one give me the real sweet sweet graphic
now uh this is mandatory fun where i get
my three best friends
in the whole wide world together to have
a little non-optional joy with me
unfortunately guys this really stinks
i've got a doctor's appointment i know
this is you have so many doctors i know
and always schedule them is this the
pediatrician listen when you're driving
a race car you got to get it tuned up
quickly okay
this is a bugatti okay not a chevy
cruise okay okay i don't think it's
funny that you chose the chevy cruze
yeah which is the car i drive yeah
[Applause]
anyway i i can't be here for mandatory
get out of here i did find someone to
replace me oh okay so if you guys can
just talk a little more paddington three
until i
got it for you i'll win this person
before i'm gonna do that um
we'll shout out a couple super chatters
td jones you asked for a mandatory fun
we're doing it now we don't know who's
going to run it also aaron love asking
for a mandatory fund or excited to see a
mandatory fund it's happening we don't
know who's going to host this mandatory
no idea we've kind of been left on our
own i'm going to be mad if it's one
person
now
i am excited for a paddington three i
will say that because i've heard how
great the paddington
i know he's from peru that no one
actually knows that like for some reason
i feel like it's lore that never no one
really was like that that's like the
whole first one
silence
it is i hollywood executive oh geez
mover and shaker about town those are my
sunglasses t michael bechtold
these are mine you have similar ones
next to us on the table
don't worry your sunglasses are
unmolested
i've never said that i never this is my
bird perseus he helps me in all
decisions good to see you again percy
all righty now
as you know
[Applause]
[Music]
perseus runs hot and cold
now
as you all know
things have been tough over at t
michael's studios we've had some recent
slip ups in our hiring department we
we accidentally hired uh
voldemort the evil wizard oh no to
direct our new feature oh and uh that
just wasn't gonna go good for us so i
need some pitches
from my [ __ ]
is that who we are that's who you guys
are you're my main crew you're my main
think tank that's a little rude you're
my think tank
because you all come with that stank you
know what i mean that spice that juice
that gets the movies flowing now
we've got three sweet cools
ghostbusters afterlife
and the knives out movie now
some of these already have titles
but we don't know the plots from each
one so
i'd like you all right now speed round
style to give me the log line for each
of these sequels
and then
the you know what comes after the colon
the squid games
quit squidding around
should
and then do the three we give you our
three yeah you choose which one everyone
start with squid game and then i'll tell
you which one has been green lit okay
i'll do mine first what's that boy
what
he wants you to go first oh okay why are
you volunteered to go first
perseus or whatever your name is i i did
volunteer to go first that's okay uh
this sequel now i know this for
for to be true i i i hacked into the
mainframe and i figured this out uh the
next squig game it's gonna be focused
you know they played kid games in the
first one they're gonna play kid games
again but this time the contestants are
children oh it's going to be children
dying which is going to be rough i'm
into it that's how it's going to be and
it's going to be squid game two
the squids are all right wow
oh yeah
my that's good
that's really good i have chills chills
i have chills because i'm very ill oh
okay i don't know well you should have
been tested when you came in i was
tested and the results were positive
i'm testing 98 percent with covert right
now audience scores say
three thumbs up this guy's got more
covered
than a wet market all right
now jessica after you um i
my pitch was this squid game
is you know yeah they were playing child
games before
but what's harder than child video games
oh you know have you tried to play
pajama sam lately it's not as easy as it
was pajamas i wasted a lot of hours
trying to play the lion king game on
super nintendo exactly
and the log line would say uh we had an
inkling
yeah
we had an inkling
that's cute
i don't get it
i'll noodle on that a little more
all right
whitney okay mine is going to be that
this season of squid games is not going
to be childhood games but rather
games that you would play in like middle
school p.e class
and so it's going to be like dodge ball
so my squid game is if you can dodge a
squid you can dodge a ball oh wow
dodgeball focus fascinating very
dodgeball fascinating but only one of
your films can be green lit for t
michael productions at the t michael
studios currently filing for chapter 37
bankruptcy chapter 37 i don't think i
want my project to be green live more
chapters than a dan brown novel that's
how many bankruptcies we have
brandon congratulations oh we're moving
forward with the squids are all right
thank you thank you glad to hear silence
up next
we have ghostbusters afterlife 2.
i need each of you to pitch me on
ghostbusters let's just assume after
life is out of it okay oh yeah
ghostbusters five technically okay
ghostbusters four for you sexist pigs
who don't acknowledge the female
ghostbusters thank you yeah exactly oh t
michael's a feminist from day one i
believe after they're done cooking and
cleaning they should work any job they
want oh god okay
hey i'm from a different era i'm from a
bygone area
listen as long as they look pretty i
don't care what job they do
it would help if they had smiled a
little more in that thing
all right oh we have one sweater i see i
[ __ ] see it dancing
i [ __ ] see it
i thought there was a pole did no one
vote on the swear
well guess what t michael took the
[ __ ] sweat
yeah thank you to our super chatters for
unlocking our swearing jar it took you
long enough unfortunately t michael has
has taken the swears perseus do you want
to swear [ __ ] you
[ __ ] off
perseus
he lost his family to a power line for
many years okay okay here's my sequel
for for ghostbusters afterlife i think
we can do this a few more minutes but
uh in this in this in this one they're
gonna go find uh the criminals that were
never caught but died you know what i
mean yeah they're gonna go find jack the
ripper
we're gonna go find the zodiac killer
get a little justice on that ghost uh
and this one's gonna be called
ghostbusters
criminal intent whoa
they're gonna do a job that the police
couldn't do in our realm they're gonna
go to the afterlife and do it you just
blew my balls
oh poor tommy he's not well is he looks
terrible looks terrible my god
i love the boy but lay off the g-fuel
just getting great product anyway
jessica
jessica as they say
jessica
stop saying my name like that yes echo
okay what pitches do you have for me in
perseus
whitney maybe you should go
i don't know um
i was gonna i was gonna go with uh uh
ghostbusters firehouse because uh [ __ ]
the ghostbusters police yeah
okay
the thin red line
exactly okay
i stand with the firefighters all right
yeah we're a firefighter family
firefighter family here
not us
we're roto-rooter family
sneak those drains
and take away the pain roto-rooter
when you just [ __ ] too much for yourself
okay okay they understand what
roto-rooter yeah i don't
um
i do
i do indeed there's percy's hair keeps
getting on my lips
what if you impress you percy is your
dog you're right next to me
um
i'm not here
read the room um i
i think ghostbusters
will be um
all of the original ghostbusters we had
right murray but they're all dead
some of them are still alive i believe
but in this world they're dead they're
dead too they've died so they're all
dead right and their ghosts are what's
haunting the new
who are you ghostbusters call when the
call
is coming from inside the firehouse that
that was my life
is over i agree with my own film once
again a white male has come up with a
perfect idea i was the only one with
this idea this idea was mine you all saw
it okay
that's how you take it from me
jessica will bring you on as an
associate producer no no that's a
producer who does a lot of work
not an executive producer who just
spends a lot of money like me
t michael bechtel jessica we're green
lighting your film i love ghosts
fighting their old friends i like that i
had a friend who was a ghost once but we
didn't fight
we'd go to a mountain and camp out once
a year
fishing and hunting
that's not what it was called it was
called fracture hill oh okay
anyway
enough of that
the knives out movie has been green lit
for a sequel and god knows we need a
plot summary and a name for that
jessica go first for us on this one okay
oh the next knives out movie yes is
gonna be called
um
it's going to be called
uh
rags to riches oh okay oh
knives out rags to riches plot summary
um
well they named it after the 50 cent
song
and i think it's going to be rags to
riches
better than
tags to [ __ ]
50 cent when i knew when me was just
called 25 cent thanks a lot biden
where was it going
to joke
that's right
uh i think the next knives out film we
obviously have glass onion but there'll
be a third one right in the trilogy yes
it'll be called knives out
knives in whoa
i always call it knives in you can call
knives out at home uh and it'll be
benoit's been murdered
has been murdered and it's gonna be all
the criminals all the criminals that he
caught trying to solve who killed the
man that caught them
so
you know what you're right think outside
they'll bring back chris evans but then
they'll bring back whoever the killer is
in glass onion and then some some some
friendly faces from think outside the
bun t michael it's not just gonna be
those two all right whitney okay
my uh knives out sequel is gonna take
place inside of an outback steakhouse
and be about the family who owns it and
the money that they will inherit should
they uh find
the the missing item hidden so like
there's gonna be like a check hidden
shirt in like a booth and they have to
like fi it's gonna be called the bloomin
onion wow
i love it unfortunately you're all wrong
okay why knives out too will be a summer
camp comedy called knives out are you
forking kidding me
it feels like you came here to take your
own pictures yeah it really does dude
t michael you must be silenced
i didn't announce this but there's a
bonus round
oh thank goodness real quick pitch me
the title of paddington three
uh i think it'll be padding uh patented
three from the cradle to the grave
uh
and he's gonna go around
damn and find all the children who
mistreated them that have grown up and
killed them i i want to go off this too
and mine will be paddington three gets
stuffed and he's just shoving stuffing
down
okay
mine's gonna be paddington three eaton
ain't cheating if it's marmalade whoa
if you're on a diet and you eat some
marmalade it's not it's not cheap today
because eating is not cheating all right
gucci gang i gotta get my blood replaced
okay i do it once a day
i have a friend named jeremy jeremy
renner heard of him yeah well it's not
that one okay okay coincidentally they
have the same name we swap blood every
day
stop name dropping well we're like one
of those hourglasses his sand goes into
me my sand goes into him only one may
live while the other is bleeding out
gotcha
we make it work we're both married to
the same woman look out all right that's
it i've got to go back to getting my
blood swapped out thank you so much team
i've got a cocaine buffet at the chateau
it's mandatory fun we really enjoyed
that team michael we really did uh that
was really nice and thank you to our
super chatters who helped us unlock that
switch the td jones the cab fare for the
doctor's appointment jones you really
put us over the top thanks so much i
know you'll have a mandatory fund uh and
ernest esteban had a great uh pitch for
squid game two murderific boogaloo oh
don't sign up for things guys yeah don't
sign up for anything i signed up for a
lot of things well a lot of free things
you should read
the fine print oh tell me you're back
guys what the doctor said well it was
crazy i was in there getting my you know
just my usual tune up and then he
offered me a pretty exciting opportunity
to trade blood with someone once a day
no if it's jeremy renner don't do it
also uh our poll to the chat said that
the great team michael had the best
pitches i think it's a little unfair for
johnson they'll name him the great also
i was gonna say your replacement yelled
at dawson
yeah yeah my replacement yelled dots
camera
i am so so sorry oh okay
michael
beck told
he's a hollywood legend so whatever you
did
obviously deserve the scorn of team
michael dodson
check the ice underneath you because
it's looking pretty thin my friend
and it's getting thinner by the day you
don't need to you don't need to go
someone someone said it's good game tax
season
that's a real squid game
if you do it right if you do it
correctly you don't die
[Laughter]
and that's the trick here
oh now we're going down to the break
room breakdown
oh
oh my
oh my
neat
uh cool so there's but wait how what am
i doing what am i reading
sorry sorry it says whitney and jessica
when i thought when he was doing it i
mean when you're we're tag team in this
listen uh look here eric voz did a
breakdown uh that we're gonna take a
look at real quick go ahead play me that
clip
at first i thought these might just be
wounds that gore endured but no no the
scarring is exactly along the lines of
those tattoos as if he scarred himself
to cover those tattoos in a specific way
so how do we explain gore's
transformation throughout this film what
causes this physical erosion this man is
mourning and for many mcu characters
scarring and tattoos like this tells us
something about their pasts obviously
for killmonger his ritualistic scarring
represented each of his kills in the
case of drax drax's tattoos are not
about his conquests but about the
memories he has with this family and how
appropriate is it then that thor in this
film when zeus flicks off his clothes
reveals how he has inked his skin with
family members he's lost loki's horned
crown with the letters r.i.p loki so for
gore the scar is now etched on the sides
of his forehead where those stripes once
were might be his attempt to do the same
to cover the basic tattoos that once
bound him to his home world a world that
no longer exists because the gods failed
to save him and instead scar himself to
memorialize the names of his wife and
children
wow okay do we
can i
can i say i think i've been yelled at
for this theory before but does anyone
think there's a possibility that those
tattoos that are on the back of thor
were just a joke that taika put in for
that 100 and that when the actual
movie comes out his back is just going
to be beautiful
i think it's still there but i don't
think it's going to have the same
connotation that eric was saying where
eric was like they clearly get these for
their like just like what their family
did and culturally i'm like no thor just
got his because he's partying he's
hanging out with the ravagers in space
and we're having a good time and just
wanted to be
i would never get an impulsive
tattoo to just be cool i'm going to pull
my sleeve up and show a through of a
baseball team from a city i'm not from
what team detroit baby go tigers motown
at least the captain small for you
that's right
do we do we agree with tommy or do we
agree with eric boss let me get a poll
in the chat no i'm joking do we agree
with boss though on his scars as
memorials does that seem i it makes
sense it makes sense i just don't think
i just don't think it is you would think
that there would be if if gore has these
divine powers or whatever which they've
teased or and like we know the
technology that exists out there
him just clawing them off in a strange
way if they were like religious symbols
and he's mad at the gods now and he's
just ripping them off out of anger i
guess that would make sense it would be
interesting if they were religious
symbols and he starts going after the
gods uh the gods did that to them as
well oh you can't have those anymore
take those off yeah yeah well it looks
okay two things really quick one fray
girl did say gore theory gore was uh
gore was erasing his connections to his
god rich
love it love that theory love that idea
buy that more than eric bosses
don't just do it at home yourself
[Applause]
okay he does have the necro sword which
we all know
does he make you switch blood with
someone else what are you talking about
okay your your people are i never i
don't trust your your recommendation my
people oh god
okay either way
you went oh god so fast
you're like i'm not entertaining that
don't do this to me also
so the two picks i don't know if you can
bring up a still of the video john for
the break room breakdown but the two
picks side by side looks like
him weaker and him
healed yeah does that is am i wrong so
do you think that with him destroying or
killing other gods maybe he is also
getting powerful and getting more
healthy i would think he's getting more
powerful yeah and like the first shot of
him right he's uh
he's there's color around him he's not
absorbing color anymore that's probably
him with his family or something on his
home planet yeah yeah eating space for
me
junior let's eat a gold yeah space
marmalade and then paddington says i'll
take those tattoos from you with my
background
just like that would we like that would
we like it if like killmonger with every
kill he did he did marketing that is
interesting every god is just like right
yeah and like you know he started he's
like oh i didn't measure that out right
it's too long i'll try and fix it oh no
oh god it's a mess yeah map out your
tattoos like when you're trying to like
cut your doll's bangs when you're a kid
[Music]
do you think killmonger started where
did killmonger start where was kill
number one probably durian here uh no
probably a lot easier
this has been the hardest part yeah well
i guess pain doesn't matter dab your
titties it hurts please he was like
you're already here first folks
if we if we get one message to the
viewing audience yeah if we get one
message out to our viewers try not to
get a tattoo on your chest don't stab
your titties
oh you did stop getting tattoos
how many tattoos do i have a hundred and
each day i'll reveal a new one oh my god
oh my god but i i i do like where voss
is coming from someone in the chat was
like i like jessica she's coming at it
like a normal person
but respect i do respect what boss is
saying it makes sense i understand and
also our job is to dig deep into these
theories where you don't even think
about it especially in parts where
you're like i wasn't thinking about his
tattoos and boss was like well i was
taking the game
i'm the one who looks like
i don't get the tattoos and so it i i
think it makes sense i think there is
something there but i also don't think
taika watiti's thinking too hard into it
if that makes sense yeah it also might
be there was a little panel i was just
going through the comics because i was
like what could these scars be from and
there was a whole panel of people just
throwing rocks at him at one point and
so i'm like well maybe that's where they
came from
it's from the one scene in the comics
where everyone was like you're
blaspheming the gods no
and then now he has just a little bundle
like a rock
yeah see look at it look at it he's just
getting rocks thrown up i do want to
point out the person who said that if we
hit 200 dollars i'll get a butt tattoo
is wrong that was just i'll get another
all right i'm simply going to get one of
my own choices
[Applause]
a thousand dollars on friday we should
get tattoos i will easily my wife will
kill me
okay jessica and i will we mark our body
needles so i can't i don't have how do
you think thor got tattoos
did you take a needle i think he just
got it through partying well the thing
is the tattoo is only getting one layer
that he just like you know like
every day i think they can still be
pierced is different than getting a
tattoo because the ink is still going in
there and the ink will probably stay but
this could be a space tattoo
so it's more it's harder starship
troopers it was just a laser yeah yeah
so if anything theirs would stick harder
than ours that's true also i would hope
that he would get them machine free
because he's like machine freaking yes
i want him to get a machine free tattoo
a little stick and poke that's okay i
think that i think that entire prison
yeah i hope he gets jailhouse tattoos
just like what do they use they use a
pocket
pin yeah a ballpoint pen with a i watch
a lot of tick tocks on this um you can
also watch a lot of tick tocks on jail
things it's very interesting yeah you
can uh we we're so excited for thor
it's coming out very soon it's right
around the corner they they put out like
a new tickets promo which had a couple
of new shots in it uh because the
tickets were on sale today i believe for
real this time so just said inkmaster
confirmed on thor 4. yeah
confirmed they've also they released a
bunch of new posters today
they put out like new posters for the
different ways you can watch thor are
you a dolby person are you the imax man
are you a regular
uh moviegoer are you screen x which i
don't even know what that means i just
like dole because it's loud i can feel
the waves in the shot go through my body
that's where the the chair moves no
that's for me and me and john went to
one of the those we went to it for the
hitman's bodyguard's wife
worst movie to see the water kept
spraying oh my god
no i i want to offer a universal studio
yeah they had a little sprays and then
me and john were that's why 20 minutes
into it done we were like i can't
believe that there is a fifth wave i
just leave that theater and go to
jurassic park there's a fifth way to see
this film and that's you wait a year and
a half for the porn parody oh okay
exactly
let's go well okay they don't have to
watch it
oh my god also the thor run time is now
is not now but i think it's been one
hour and fifty years more run time is
less than the stranger things
it says
i was talking about this earlier
how many times do you see a marvel movie
with your friends and then you walk out
and one of your friends is always like i
could have cut 25 minutes off that movie
or like i think sometimes you see a
marvel movie with your friends and one
of them walks out and they're like bro i
peed my pants because it was way too
long
you gotta go to the bathroom not a
problem here tommy does use the bathroom
a lot it's tough i gotta judge how much
coke zero i drink before the fountain i
just yeah i gotta make it am i the only
person that can go into a movie and not
have to use the battery
i literally will never use the back i'm
a thirsty boy
brandon and i got two 14-pound bowling
balls next in our prostates okay so
you're lucky we're even alive
yeah we get it john it's over oh my god
nerds you're done
we've maybe had enough show for today we
want to thank you all for for checking
out and our super chatters uh we had a
couple uh
ones we didn't mention jimmy star stuff
saying i'm going to get a tattoo of
tommy's face over my own face
jimmy please don't send a photo that'll
show those face readers what's up uh
really confusing tsa or just get his
money yeah
chrissy pointing out sherry had a really
cool hexagon tattoo on her hand which is
exactly how carbon atoms are arranged
when they flat to make graphene graphene
is what the molecular makeup of
vibrating we got to have chrissy on this
show no she's too smart we just gotta
keep her in the chat
we should go out on this one okay all
right this i feel like this is a tic tac
in the making okay and daschle can
camera for everyone as we do it okay
i'll i'll leave it off tell me you'll do
the first one okay omni fan this is a
tic-tac-prompt and tick-tock you're
always getting this wrong you don't
understand how povs work okay the pov is
oh i know how pov is working you're
going to see spider-man no way homie uh
he's spelled it no way homie uh but
after the title it's morbid time so you
go to see the extra extended cut a
spider-man no way home
it turns out it's actually just morbid
time just warped this is the pov tell me
what's your face
okay jessica give me give me the pov
this is me looking at my phone at the
right ticket did i get the right ticket
okay
whitney what's your pov i'm second dick
in the movie theater
whoa
i'll give you a picture i figured it's
the end of the show
[Laughter]
why did you choose spider-man no way
home
that's our show that's a jurassic world
move if i ever saw one that's a break
room we'll see you tomorrow thank you
roomies thank you
come back any time life finds a way we
love you have a great rest of your
monday uh we'll see you tomorrow right
here on the break room goodbye
[Music]
[Music]
you